[Music]
so thanks for that very warm
introduction Brian I'm gonna talk to
everyone today about this project the
event horizon telescope project it is
this long labor of love
it's a visionary project that a number
of us started a while ago
we started with about 20 people just a
few people going to the tops of
mountains to do interesting observations
now were 200 people so this really is
the story of a building of a team to do
something that we thought was impossible
and the idea at the beginning was to
make a picture of a supermassive black
hole something that had never been done
before and if we could do this we'd be
able to test Einstein's theory of
gravity in the one place where it might
break down the boundary of a black hole
and more than that we'd be able to look
at the physics involved at the very
centers of galaxies where we think that
all of these black holes that are
supermassive exist
every galaxy has one of these at its
center and they power this luminosity at
the center of these galaxies that can
outshine the combined light of all the
stars in the host galaxy now how does
this happen the only way to do this is
to build a telescope that can see peer
into the center of these galaxies so the
idea was to build this earth sized
telescope to allow us to do that and to
set the stage I want to start off with
this image which is an optical image of
the galaxy of Hercules a it's 2 billion
light years away it weighs about a
thousand times what our Milky Way galaxy
does and you're seeing the optical light
but when you look at it in the radio you
see something really interesting as this
should knock your socks off providing
that your socks are not on too tight
right the this is these are Jets of
material screaming from the center of
this galaxy of near light speed they
span about one-and-a-half million light
years to power this jet requires about
20 billion super novae going off over
the lifetime of this thing 20 billion
suns exploding and it's not just this
explosion it's a directed
explosion and we think the only thing
that can be responsible for this
directed power output is a spinning
black hole accreting matter and erupting
these jets from the north and south pole
along the spin axis and the goal of the
event horizon telescope is to peer
deeply into the center of this but first
gravity okay so in 1915 Einstein came
with his theory of general relativity
and he redefined what gravity was as a
geometric bending of space-time so
matter deformed space-time and then
things move in that deform space-time
and one of the initial predictions was
that during a total solar eclipse you
should be able to see the deviation of
light as it just comes around the limb
of the Sun and you would see stars
appear to be in different parts of the
sky based on that light bending the
total extent of that light building was
about 1 mm of a degree and then that in
1919 Arthur Eddington with two
expeditions verified looking at this
total solar eclipse that the Stars shown
here in the middle of those horizontal
bars had moved at exactly Einstein's
predictions and not Newtons and
overnight Einstein became a household
name redefined how we thought about
gravity and the way that large-scale
structure should exist in the universe
the year after 1915 in 1916 this man
called Schwarzschild who has possibly
the best mustache I have ever seen in my
entire life it was on the front lines of
World War one calculating the trajectory
of shells you know going over in the
military field and he sat down and he
solved Einstein's equations I don't know
how he did that I can't even get started
without a cup of coffee in the morning
he's got shells going over his head and
he solves these equations and he shows
that if you have enough matter in a
small enough volume you get to the point
where you have an event horizon and
that's the point where gravity is so
strong that light can't escape this is
where black holes are born but they're
really just mathematical constructs
maybe we don't know that they exist in
the universe we don't know we can
actually see one but mathematically they
exist and the question we have before us
is what would happen if we had infinite
resolution goggles what if we could look
into the center
one of these galaxies what would we see
now what happens is that matter is
moving around the black hole like this
circular orbit right so you get this
pancake of material all funneling slowly
into the black hole and what John Pierre
lumen a found in 1979 was that you see
the back part of this disk of material
ends up over the black hole you never
want to try to hide behind a black hole
okay because it will always see you and
you wind up with this shadow feature
here whose dimensions were figured out
using a solution to Einstein's equations
to be the square root of 27 times that
Schwarzschild radius let me break this
down for you a little bit if you were to
see a supermassive black hole in the
center of a galaxy you'd see a shadow
formed by the event horizon and the
extent of that shadow would be the
square root of 27 times some just a
handful of fundamental constants
including the mass of the black hole so
if you want to have a real challenge and
you want to see if you can calculate the
square root of 27 this is what you want
to do okay this is what Jean Pierre
illuminae drew in 1979 and I've showed
this because this is really a
convergence of art and science he really
didn't have the graphing software that
we have today that can make beautiful
images this was hand drawn with about
10,000 points on negative paper using
Indian ink and it came from a computer
simulation but he hand drew this another
labor of love and he gave us our first
glimpse of what a black hole shadow
might look like and what we might be
able to measure to test Einstein's
theories if that was the square root of
27 across and Schwarzschild radii
Einstein would be right now this is what
it looks like when you really do some of
the ray tracing now remember I told you
that the light bending on these stars
was 1 mm of a degree here you see full
loop-de-loops around this red circle
which shows the event horizon and when
you get many many photons a lot of light
moving around the black hole you wind up
seeing this screen and on the screen you
wind up seeing this this black hole
shadow okay and again the size of this
is about the square root of 27 times
this force I radio now why do we see so
much light that's because a lot of gas
and dust is trying to get close to the
black hole
but the volume is so small that you wind
up through friction heating that gas to
hundreds of billions of degrees so we in
a paradox of their own gravity
black holes are some of the brightest
things in the sky and again they can
outshine the combines starlight of all
the stars in that galaxy and this is
what you should wind up seeing and this
is the square root of 27 that we're
after so we're trying to build something
you can see that the problem is that
these are some of the smallest objects
in the universe in order to see this you
would need to be able to build a
telescope that could read the date on a
quarter in Los Angeles while you're
standing here in New York City piece of
cake okay now this is our best
understanding with supercomputers of
what we should be seeing right because
you don't wind up seeing just the square
root of 27 and a nice bright ring
there's wisps of gas coming in there's
chaotic motions of the fluid so you wind
up seeing something that's a little bit
messy but you still see very clearly
that circle and that circle is the
photon orbit now let's go to what we
actually measured this is m87 Messier 87
it's called Messier 87 because Messier
was looking for things that were not
comets he was a comet hunter and so he
started making a list of things that
were uninteresting to him because they
looked a little bit like comets but they
really weren't comets so this is number
this is number 87 and this is a Hubble
Space Telescope image and if you rotate
it and you you carve out a little piece
of it you see this jet that's coming out
just like the Jets I showed you before
this is in the optical this is an
optical light this is what you would see
with your with your naked eye and if you
overlay that on the radio image so if
you had radio goggles you also see this
jet and they overlaid perfectly but what
you wind up seeing is only one side of a
jet that's because this jet is coming
almost exactly towards us and just as a
train whistle gets higher in pitch when
it's coming towards you and lower in
pitch when it's going away from you this
is much brighter when it's coming at you
and the reason you don't see the
opposite jet is because it's almost
going directly into the screen okay so
one is coming out you one is going away
from you
one is bright and one is dim but you do
wind up seeing this ghostly shockwave
here where the unseen jet is plowing
into the intergalactic medium okay so
we're doing a little bit of scientific
sleuthing here finding out that there is
actually a second chapter when you go
all the way to the center of that jet
this is the best image we have so far so
this is the best radial image we have
the center of that galaxy and you wind
up seeing this jetted structure just
beginning to come out here but in order
to see the shadow we would have to zoom
in by another factor of 10 to see what's
going on there
now it's very very difficult to do that
okay if you wanted to build a normal
telescope like the ones you see here
these large satellite dishes the
magnifying power is essentially equal to
the wavelength of light you're observing
divided by the size of the dish so just
think you want to go very small
wavelengths very big dishes to see very
small things on the sky in the parlance
of radio astronomy we call that lambda
over D that's the resolution of your
telescope and the way a normal telescope
works is you've got this beautiful
parabolic surface light waves hit that
parabolic surface and they all bounced
off and combine at the same point the
same time where the focus is and you put
your camera there and that is where you
see the combined light so the event
horizon telescope we couldn't make a
telescope as big as we needed to because
if you wanted to see all the way through
to the center of the black hole the
center of the galaxy with the black hole
is you need to observe at wavelengths of
about one millimeter
about that big and if you find out if
you say to yourself I want to read the
date on a quarter in Los Angeles when
I'm here in New York I would need to
build a telescope as large as the earth
to do that so what we do is we
effectively take these dishes smash them
with a ball-peen hammer and take little
shards of reflectivity and put them at
different parts of the earth we use
telescopes around the earth we Network
them together to give us a telescope
effectively as large as the earth itself
this is the technique we use is called
very long baseline interferometry that's
kind of an acronym salad I'm gonna walk
you through it in just a couple of
seconds so we have these two radio
telescopes on either side of the world
they're looking at the same black hole
at the same time radio waves are coming
in and they hit one telescope first then
the other telescope little boy later
and we have these two video telescopes
here that essentially work like light
buckets collecting all the photons all
the ways and we use hydrogen maser
clocks these are atomic clocks that lose
only one second every 10 million years
to make sure that we time tag all the
data perfectly and that's because we
want to bring them together later and
compare them at a central facility that
we call a correlator so they when you
think about it we're doing exactly the
same thing as the optical dish but
instead of using the geometry of this
surface to bounce things to the same
place at the same time we store them on
hard disks play them back later align
them perfectly in time and then we
combine them and we wind up with a
telescope as big as the distance between
these telescopes it's kind of magic I
fell in love with it as a graduate
student and I never looked back so it's
really there's really something mystical
about it I also say that the amount of
data that we record is petabytes and the
only way to get all that data back to a
central facility is to load it onto a
747 you can't beat the bandwidth of a
747 loaded with hard disk drives as a
matter of fact when I takes two of these
modules that we use to record on and I
walk across the stage I am faster than
the fastest internet in the entire world
we calculated how long it would take to
get data back from let's say the South
Pole station that I'll show you in a
moment
25 years so it's much better to keep the
disks down there while the station is
closed wait for ASCII equipped plane to
go in bring it back out that's much
faster so there's one part that's
missing though if you have a bunch of
different telescopes around the world
you essentially just have little silver
bits of this virtual dish thankfully the
Earth rotates for a number of different
reasons but but for us this is really a
big one and so what you're seeing on
this screen over here is the effective
virtual dish on the right and it gets
filled in as the Earth rotates all right
so your telescopes in the South Pole and
Hawaii and Spain they all form these
baselines or pairs of telescopes that
sweep around as the Earth rotates and
gives us a full filled dish that we can
use to make an image so this is the
array that we started with we began in
the early days we're just a few
the scopes the SMT in Arizona the JCM or
the J CMT and SMA in Hawaii for our
first measurements that showed us that
there was something very very small in
the center of our own galaxy and an m87
we use now the South Pole telescope
edition all of the Alma and op X in the
high Atacama Desert in Chile and our
colleagues in Spain have brought in this
year on thirty meter telescope in the
southern part of Spain and we have LMT
in Mexico and we're adding new
telescopes all the time but in April
2017 it all came together right we got
time on all of these telescopes and we I
think this is next and then we built
these new back ends these new bits of
instrumentation to tie them all together
so the secret sauce of the event horizon
telescope is that we didn't use dishes
that we made we used existing dishes all
over the world and we adapted them to
work together in this network of linked
telescopes so we went to the top rim to
the Atacama Desert where there was a
billion dollar telescope there and we
said allow us to rummage around in your
electronics give us card Blom's to do
what we need to do to make this work
with all the other telescopes around the
globe and amazingly they did because we
put together a team that was there was
wonderful
that showed that we could do this kind
of work and they let us do do these
modifications but what's interesting
here is that this is Moore's law this is
the amount of data you record at each
site and this is the year and this blue
curve is Moore's law maybe you've heard
of that you know roughly a doubling of
capacity of electronics every year it's
rare in fundamental physics to be able
to keep pace with Moore's law but by
hitching our wagon to 13 year old gamers
I highly recommend doing that if you
want to do some cutting edge astronomy
we were able to increase the bandwidth
of our systems in keeping with Moore's
law so this system here records 64 Giga
bits per second which is about a factor
of 32 beyond anything that had been
conceived of before and that gave us the
sensitivity we needed to detect these
black holes on these long baselines and
build this for the size telescope so now
I'm going to take you on a little tour
of the universe we start off at the
atacama array and we're gonna go deep
into the Virgo constellation where
Messier 87 lives and we start off going
through our own galaxy but then pretty
soon we're in intergalactic space and
you see coming into focus here the
beginnings of m87 like the large scale
structure around m87 where those Jets
are disrupting somebody or the activity
around there the galaxy and you start
seeing these Jets emerge personally
optical and then you wind up seeing
radio jets now we're shifting into the
radio spectrum and the center is always
unresolved you keep seeing these Jets
and you don't see anything until you
wind up getting to this image this is
what we found after two years of
crunching the data and it's fair to say
that this really knocked our socks off I
mean this was a moment that I don't
think anybody in the team will ever
forget seeing this image is kind of swim
into view what you're seeing here is the
last orbit that light takes around a
supermassive black hole that's the ring
the center part is due to the event
horizon of the black hole that's where
light rays that want to come to us first
intersect the event horizon that's the
point where even light can't escape the
gravitational field of the black hole
and then even more you wind up seeing
this brightening on the on the southern
part now why is that that's because
you're really seeing light speed motions
of the hot gas around the black hole and
when it's coming towards you it's
brighter and when it's going away from
you on the top its dimmer so not only
are you seeing the paths of light take
around takes around the black hole
you're also seeing the motions the
relativistic the near light speed
motions of gas around the black hole
this verifies Einstein's theories to the
precision of our measurements do they're
about ten or twenty percent it also puts
on very solid footing all of the
simulations we've been doing over
decades to see what these black holes
look like they really do look like what
we think they should and more than that
we have a laboratory to really study
black holes in a way we never had
before we've laid a ruler across
space-time and we verified Einstein
using an earth-sized telescope
that was our reaction too but now I want
to tell you how we did it it wasn't easy
and we really had to guard against human
bias to child with a hammer everything
starts looking like a nail right so we
want to see a shadow everything starts
looking like a shadow so to combat human
your preferences to see what you want to
see we split up into four individual
teams we had region one the Americas
region two more of a global team East
Asian team and then across Atlantic team
number three and four there and each
group got the data and each group worked
for about six or seven weeks in complete
isolation nobody knew what the other
groups were doing different algorithms
different people and the reason as I
like to say is because it's very
difficult to tell the difference between
fried chicken and labradoodles don't
laugh this is very serious
because even you get people in a room
and they all start thinking they're
looking at labradoodles they'll all
agree it's a labradoodle but it's
actually something else right so you
really want to guard against groupthink
and if you think this is hard then of
course the Chihuahua versus blueberry
muffin is is absolutely just mind
boggling ly difficult okay so this is
why we decided that we had to split
people up and send him to their
different corners now when we all got
together after these six weeks this is
what we found
now this was a celebratory moment I like
to call this our beer moment because we
didn't really know everything but this
is like we were kind of celebrating but
it wasn't champagne yet and the reason
is that these were a little bit
different but we all found this ring
like structure that came very clearly
through the data it was kind of
undeniable that we had this kind of
structure and this happened at heart
near at Harvard University July 24th
this was many this was over a year after
we took the first data
okay so we're really doing our due
diligence on this and this was everybody
in this one moment when we first
got our looks at these images a lot of
smiles what's very important here is
that there's an equal number of people
on a speakerphone all around the world
that are celebrating with us this really
was a wonderful group achievement and I
couldn't be prouder of the entire team
that that carried this out so then we
tried to make it go away we did
everything that we could to make these
images disappear how did we do that well
on the top you wind up seeing here
different kinds of shapes that could
mimic the data that we had and I'll show
you what the data looks like in a moment
you'll understand but we had a very
characteristic shape of the data when
you plot it in a certain way and it
could be mimicked by a ring an
asymmetric ring even a filled disk or
even two sources side by side so we took
all the algorithms that we had we had
three basic algorithms and we made fake
data set after fake data set after fake
data set adding all of the errors that
we knew existed in our system turbulence
in the atmosphere noisy electronics
right you know polarization filters that
were not quite pure enough so we put all
that into the data and then we tested it
to make sure that every time we put
these fake data into our algorithms we
got exactly what we put in we put in a
double you get a double when you put it
in this filled disk you get a filled
disk and when we had these algorithm is
very finely tuned then we made our final
images which were these so what you're
seeing here is three totally different
methods all giving the same answer with
the same data there are not doubles
they're not filled disks you really are
seeing a shadow beyond a shadow of a
doubt yes I said that
now so let me tell you a little bit
about why in VLBI this is with real
estate its location location location so
what you're gonna see here is this is
what happens when you have only two
stations when you have Mexico and
Arizona together you this is the virtual
aperture the virtual telescope I was
showing you before you went it with two
little points here all you can really
tell is the size of the source you get
this blob it's when you add a third
station here the Chilean station the
Atacama Desert then since they're all
kind of on a line here all you can
really tell us that it's a little bit
smaller than it was before
it's when you add this outrigger in
Hawaii that's when you begin to see
enough of a triangulation theyyou that
this this ring starts swimming into view
and after you get the European telescope
that's when you get that ring so in the
future what we want to do is want to add
more telescopes to the array to sharpen
our focus and to bring all these
features more finely into detail than we
had before now what you're gonna see
here is an animation I'm going to walk
you through this a little bit on here
you'll see the earth rotating and every
time you see two telescopes active that
bar will be flashing every day and
you'll see in an additive way all of the
telescopes contributing to this virtual
aperture this virtual dish and here
you'll see the actual data and I'll show
you what that means in a moment and
these are the three different techniques
that we used so the first thing you see
is the earth is rotating you're
collecting some of the data and you see
all the different techniques getting
better and better and better in
completely different ways as you add
more data okay and at the very end
there's still rotating gear this is the
plot I was telling you about before so
what you're seeing here is you're seeing
the amount of energy that is detected on
two of these dishes for example the one
linked here by this Purple Line versus
the distance between those dishes right
so the farther away you get the higher
resolution your telescope is when you're
over here your telescope does not have
very high resolution here you
a large scale structure here you're
looking at very very finely grained
structure and to a radio astronomer like
me who does Fourier transforms does
mathematics in their head and they see
something like this when I first saw
this I knew we had something because
it's these dips
it's that dip that comes in here the
arch and you dip down here that is a
smoking gun for a ring like structure
all right so the data really are very
clear and we but we did spend a lot of
time trying to make these things go away
to convince ourselves that we had what
we really thought we did and then we
spent some time and actually a lot of
early career researchers spent a lot of
time working on methods for measuring in
a very clear statistical way how big
this ring was so we had three different
methods I'm only showing you one here of
finding out exactly what this the radius
of this ring was right this is the
radius this is a histogram here showing
you know how many values you wind up
getting so we're very clear value of the
size of this ring and these down here
with the width of the ring and this is
what we were after the shadow diameter
should be equal to the square root of 27
times a handful of constants the mass of
a black hole the distance to the black
hole the speed of light and Newton's
gravitational constant it's so simple
it's so pure and when we saw this
swimming to view it was it was
revelatory that you could make this
prediction it's so rare and astronomy in
physics to get a prediction that's so
clean that is then so purely verified it
was a Pinchus moment so so what do we
want to go from here everywhere right so
what you're seeing here is all of the
the purple lines are the ones that we
have currently and all the blue lines
are what we might want to go in the
future we may want to go in the future
by the middle of the next decade by 2025
and if we could do that we'd wind up
filling in this virtual mirror so well
that we'd be able to make unparalleled
images not just of the black hole but of
the link to the jet that's screaming out
a denier
Lightspeed's so let me show you what
that looks like on the left hand you see
a simulation done by one of the graduate
students in our group and Rochelle you
see the black hole right here which is
in the very center but you also see
these wisps of material that linked the
black hole to the jet this is how the
black hole launches jets with magnetic
fields locked into the event horizon of
the black hole
imagine big strands of spaghetti
whipping around at near light speed and
then charged particles are forced to
move along those field lines so like
beads on a wire they're flung out that
close to the speed of light okay so we
wind up getting something in this
direction there's also one going behind
here but again that's Doppler D boosted
it's moving away from us so it's very
faint
and what you wind up seeing is that with
the array that I showed you before you
can reconstruct that almost perfectly we
can't do that now so this is what we
want to go in the future and then we
want to make movies I said it we want to
make black hole movies right the human
intellectual palette gets sophisticated
pretty quickly you know so it wasn't
five minutes after we revealed this
image that people were saying what's
next so now we have to promise something
else it's gonna be movies and what what
you're seeing here is some some
visionary work done by other researchers
in in the team Michael Johnson Cady
Bauman and others and they're working on
ways to take the data we have now in the
upper right this is the array we have
now and with certain regular risers with
certain techniques that we use in the
imaging process we may be able to make
images but when we have many many dishes
as you see down here then we can make
true movies of this spiral structure as
it orbits around the black hole and that
gives us access to a completely
different test of Einstein the shadow is
light moving around the black hole these
orbits are matter moving around the
black hole completely different kinds of
tests so one is the period of orbits and
the other one is the light bending
around the singularity and then
sometimes you don't want to be limited
by the dimensions of the earth if we can
get a low Earth orbiting satellite we'd
wind up filling in that virtual plane
here so quickly that we'd be able to
make movies so this is what we do right
now we wait for the earth to rotate over
an eight hour period just to take one
picture
if we had an orbiting satellite that
moves around once every hour we'd be
able to fill that in almost perfectly
look at that you were almost a filled
aperture you're almost getting to the
optical case so I want to wind up here
with with saying that we started small
there was a time when we were working on
some of this initial the initial
experiments but we didn't know what know
if it would work it was a very high-risk
enterprise and and some of us kind of
well in a way staked our reputations on
being able to do this and it did pay off
because after the first experiments we
knew that we could do it and then the
joy of it really has really been
building a team now 200 people strong to
make the this earth sized telescope and
here we are in Nijmegen Holland at our
last collaboration meeting we represent
60 Institute's 20 countries and regions
around the globe to build the global
telescope truly you need a global team
and what I like to say about this is
that in these times of interesting
divisions this technique this very long
baseline interferometry technique that
makes no size telescope nimbly sidesteps
all of that and it focuses only on what
brings us together your true visionary
science in the pursuit of something that
we were told we couldn't do so we're we
have a lot of these are the main people
who are part of the stakeholder groups I
want to make sure that everybody knows
we have a lot of people around the globe
helping us these are all the people who
are supporting us again we also get
support from the Templeton Foundation
from the Gordon Betty Moore Foundation
and the National Science Foundation in
addition to many international funding
agencies these people have taken a leap
of faith on this project this is basic
science and if you know what is going to
happen at the end of your basics end of
your research it's not really basic
science because you know what good is
gonna come of it basic science is when
you take a risk and you say I don't know
really how this is going to affect me
but I know that it is worth doing so if
you were to ask Ian Stein Einstein you
know what good is your theory of general
relativity he would not have been able
to tell you and if you had told him look
100 years from now you'll be able to
take your phone and using your equations
GPS will work too late
know where you are within a few feet on
the ground he would've been so excited
he would've said what's a phone right I
mean I was like so so long ago you know
they were you know people were
delivering milk with horses back then
right so sometimes you have to wait a
long time to do this and we've had great
partners that have helped us and then
I'm gonna end with this we were really
surprised with what happened we had this
image and we woke up the next day in our
hotels in Washington DC after the press
conference it was above the fold on all
the major newspapers why why was that we
couldn't really understand it in China
and you know Europe in the United States
I think it's because again we tried to
do something that was impossible you
know on the face of it seeing a black
hole is impossible and we tried to do
that they they said that there's no way
it could be done we found a way to do it
with building an earth-sized telescope
and then we built a team of people
unified by a common science vision and
we gave early career researchers just
the freedom to imagine what was possible
and everybody came through and that has
been really a joy so if this is a result
that inspires us and we hope it inspires
you to thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]